would you like to hear a rap about
carpet what do you want to be more
specific a shag carpet what it what did
you try to add something to what did you
say Persian rugs okay well we'll do shag
Persian rug carpets definitely a type of
carpet shag Persian rug carpets you guys
over here what you want to rap about I
don't think there could be two things
further apart than sexy beach tennis and
trout fishing sexy beach tennis and
trout fishing shag Persian rug carpets
that's three so far let's come to the
this this kind of spit here what you
guys want Iraq that you said Bruce Lee
you said trains I'm gonna say that Bruce
Lee is more exciting and you saw was a
fourth of July you very few weeks to
later afraid I I also it's weird isn't
it because in your country you say the
day month then day don't you reliable
gas third and in Britain we say the day
than the month we're like oh you know
the second of December but then the only
one you don't do it on is fourth of July
which is the most American day so you
can't leave our country and keep our
date for that one day that's not a
lacquered this then lovely people it's a
treat for you to close out the show it's
a freestyle rap made up entirely on the
spot but to tally all those suggestions
and don't worry it's not going to be as
bad as many of you are expecting it to
be
so we drop that beat let's put some
volume in it as well
did you chuckles I said drop that beat
I'm excited okay it's dropping now this
is gonna be super fun baby will and they
will star with okay we'll start on the
man over there I like it a red salmon in
the Yemen then I had my one wish in get
a Rodney then I go trout fishing yeah I
feel a tight shiver in my liver I'm
standing there casting on my line in the
river got a Timelord route which I can't
find and don't let the sea ones don't
let the brine the water too salty so I
get a quick flow how many trout's you
catch how big bro about this big is what
I say sadly that's the trout the go away
the only ones that are brought back
there in there I pull out produce at I
need it left is it a trout they asked me
fine fellow I say now probably a little
minnow I can't catch anything I'm
frustrated maybe my hook should have
been baited the last time I was being in
reaches when I was masturbating lying
back on the beach why would I do that
here is where the tens is ten out of ten
while they're playing beach tennis I see
these teeny bikinis forehand back and it
involves freely that's what they do and
due respect these Serena Williams Andy
Murray so sexy if they're on the beep
spray in those backhands I deserve to
get that all the sand in the toes when
they hit it down and above the sexy
Beach tennis is the thing I love
that's a tennis pun yeah
killer man I've got a nice thing it's a
Turkish Ottoman and underneath there you
know is deserving something to fish near
ottoman that's a Persian rug I'm a real
thug when I flow such thick pile look
out below is like two inches of fabric
there you drop your phone and they will
get lost in there yeah this carpets been
trodden down he used to be wipe and now
it's kind of beige brown all of the dirt
and all the shag pile is gone down beam
here 41 years a damn wild next in I'm
gonna set free let my fists go like my
name's Bruce Lee BL you will punch you
in the head and the chest and punch you
in the neck until you've got none left
just two guys of her blood he's knockin
off your dome I'll be saying what your
movies comfort of my home on my throne
that's a sofa or a couch I'm a loafer I
say when it comes to kungfu he is no
slouch is he the best I never thought
I'd plan maybe we start a test with
Jackie Chan go one-on-one and they would
have fun and Jackie Chan still has a
surviving son that's a sick burn yes
sorry Brandon you had a child now but
you don't have one
[Music]